and you're live
now good afternoon everybody we'll
resume the uh public inquiry um we're
now um
at the stage where we're hearing the
second witness of um the appellant uh
namely Mr Armstrong so I'll allow uh Mr
knuk to introduce um Mr Armstrong and
then once the uh examination in Chief
has occurred I'll ask Mr Wilcox if he
has any questions he wishes to put to Mr
Armstrong I see I've been supplied with
some documents um I'll we'll go through
those in due course but I suspect
they're the the schedule of conditions
and the um section 106 and the thank you
very much I I'll number those um in due
course I'll give those inquiry document
numbers in due course so I'll I'll let
kuk carry on with his examination in
Chief thank you
sir Mr Armstrong let me introduce your
name is Jeff Armstrong is that correct
that's correct and you hold a Bachelor
of Arts honors degree in Town and
Country planning you're a member of the
royal town planning Institute you're a
director of Armstrong rig planning uh
and you have 38 years planning
experience is that correct yes correct
and prior to establishing Armstrong rig
you worked for a number of local
authorities including London docklands
runny me uh as well as DPP where you
were an executive director is that
correct that's correct um you've visited
the site you're familiar uh with the
locality and you were instructed in
January 2022 two um to act in respect of
the application is that correct that's
correct and you tell us that your
evidence is true to the best of your
knowledge and belief is that correct it
is indeed yes um I'd like you to start
Mr Armstrong with just a point of rising
out the evidence of Mr
milest so the
application we know all matters Reserve
sa for Access access means the points of
access and so accordingly what this
propos needs to do is to demonstrate one
way in which what is proposed can be
appropriately laid out and address
through the reserve matters correct now
um the first thing to probably just
touch on is in terms of design if you
turn to your
appendix
three sorry your appendix 2 we in fact
have a design technical paper don't we
we do that's correct okay well I don't I
don't need to go anything further
through that but that that sets out a
summary of the design process and how
high quality design can ultimately be
delivered through the reserve matters is
that correct that's correct and then the
inspector was making wasn't making the
point respectfully was asking questions
about the nature of the application and
what may be secured by conditions and
through the reserve matters application
if you could turn please to the
statement of common
ground at
3.8 yes got
that and if you could also have to hand
CD
2.7 uh sorry that's not right CD
1.27 yes I've got
that and effectively when the
application was submitted it was
submitted with a framework
plan and that framework master plan was
a plan for
determination correct and that included
the areas of built development and the
areas effectively of open space is that
correct that's correct what what we
might think of as a parameters plan and
the local Authority um stated that they
didn't want that as to be a plan for
determination they thought that it could
all be dealt with through the reserve
matters application that's correct okay
I I'm effectively just summarizing
what's in the statement of common ground
right so if we just take it in stages
firstly can the reserve matters
appropriately secure a design which sets
out the built development and the areas
of landscaping and the high quality
Landscaping that we have discussed is
the reserve matters adequate to do that
yes it's it's it's for the council as
the local planning authority to take the
information take the information
contained in the outline and then secure
the open space the buffers the
Landscaping through the reserve matters
if however it was considered to be
necessary to secure those particular
parameters firstly could the framework
master plan be considered as a plan for
determination bearing in mind its formal
Mission yes it could and and as I said
before this that was our original
intention was for this plan to be um
conditioned as part of the outline for
compliance with the RM in the in the
future and if then there was to be a
condition which required the reserve
matters to be submitted and determined
in accordance with the framework master
plan and the landscape strategy what's
your view as to whether that would then
secure those parameters and effectively
mean that the detailed points that Mr
mil was addressing are the correct
factual basis on which to assess the
proposal yes it it would um uh provide
the clarity for what the reserve matter
was going to be in the future it would
clarify um the delivery of the landscape
buffer which we've obviously spent some
time discussing and providing evidence
on so it just gives that extra uh
security that that these key points are
delivered as part of the RS thank you
right so let's start please with your
evidence at
[Applause]
2.7 and we see then that there was a
recommendation for approval and it's
agreed at the times of the determination
there were no outstanding requests for
further information no objection from
statutory consules a recommendation from
the officer endorsed by the director
what weight do you say should attach to
that consensus of professional
assessment I I think that should have
significant weight um it was
the the processing of the application
with the officers the pre-application
discussion we had clearly the the the DM
officer had discussion with the policy
team and we'll come back to that later
but clearly the determination the
recommendation for
approval uh was one which the officers
thought long and hard about they they
just had their fiveyear supply removed
and so they had to look at were there
any sound reasons for this site to come
for to be recommended for approval and
the report clearly sets all those issues
out and should be given uh due weight
accordingly
uh next please if you look at your 2.9
the reason for
refusal beyond the location outside the
settlement
boundary what other reason is given for
refusal none it's it's it's it's it's
clear that that's that is the the clux
of the matter in hand okay and so what
you've referred to and melan friend
picked up on it in opening is this use
of the term well there is a technical
conflict with s1s 2 and S8 yes what do
you mean by
technical um what I mean by technical is
that it's that one particular issue
which flows through the policies so in
other words there are other component
parts to those policies but the the
conflict stems only from the fact that
we're developing outside the settlement
boundary not I say from any other limb
from those particular policies yeah is
there any land use
consequence land uce impact which flows
from the location outside the settlement
boundary no there isn't no no um by
using the term technical in that way
there's
no luse consequence which flows from it
are you suggesting tell us that somehow
technical means well not really
something to be taken seriously the
conflict with the development plan um I
I I think it's the way the way we've
presented it is on the basis that it's
we acknowledge that there is a breach of
the policies so we're not trying to
suggest otherwise but in terms of the
scale of the breach the fact that it's a
a technical or part of or maybe there
was a better phrase we could have used
that it it wasn't a series of conflicts
stemming from various uh elements of
those particular policies it was just
that one particular aspect of putting a
development site outside the settlement
boundary okay so let's maybe try and do
this without reference to some documents
if we can the the development plan I'll
assume a large amount of knowledge if I
can the housing requirement in policy S2
is 310 dwellings per anom correct um
what was the basis of the uplift from
294 in the draft to
310 in policy
S2 um The Uplift was uh was twofold one
was to
deliver uh the employment opportunities
which the council were looking for I
think in the region of 2000 200000 jobs
uh and the uplift was was also linked to
the affordable housing provision and
does that minimum requirement of 2,000
jobs to 2029 in policy E1 is that extent
or not no it's still it's still current
today and so what reason if any is there
to reduce that the housing requirement
to 2029 as a minimum no I I I think the
the 310 is is still the the target set
in the in the local plan and is still
the target which the council need to be
in place to meet their uh very strict
objectives which they set when they
adopted the plan and so if I look please
at policy
S2 so CD 3.1 policy
S2 it's page 18 mhm
S2 yes
please uh it's page 20 of the
PDF yep and that then identifies a
supply of
5108 and if I look at the table on page
18 page 22 of the PDF what are the
sources of the
supply the sources are the allocations
and those neighborhood plans which um
allocate sites and a windfall allowance
of 300 so it's a very
specific
um makeup of that housing requirement
and if you were to just be sufficiently
interested to scroll to the glossery and
the definition of windfall
um I'll just I'll just read it out so
it's page 138 of the PDF it says
windfall sites are sites which have not
been specifically identified as
available in the local plan process they
normally comprise previously develop
sites that have unexpectedly become
available so with that limited windfall
allowance what was envisaged by the plan
what would be the source of that of that
windfall
allowance uh well the source would have
been PDL sites in in within settlement
boundaries yeah and so with that in mind
if you look at
227 and 2.29 of the plan so 2.27 and
2.29
mhm what what
is the spatial distribution of housing
as
planned well spatial distribution is is
focused on the three
key three three key urban areas that the
council have have focused on from from
from day one and in
229 what was planned in terms of growth
in the rural
Villages uh very limited it was 300 in
total and so what then is the role of
the settlement boundaries in the context
of that spatial distribution of housing
well the settlement boundaries then then
are very rigid in there and the way they
are seen in terms of these policies IES
and um any development which would be
outside of those uh settlement
boundaries um would be open for the
council to
resist um in terms of the way these
policies are actually um presented and
then in terms of policy S8 on page 50 I
see the settlement hierarchy and the
categories and and what was the evidence
base at 2104 for the categorization of
the settlements
um it was 2.14 there are three documents
referred to there so one with the
district rural facility survey included
in there
okay now the plan then was examined and
found sound post nppf 2012 yes um so
what conclusion did the inspector reach
about soundness one of the tests being
consistency with national
policy yeah the the the
inspector um on the basis of the
evidence provided found that although
challenging was happy to to effectively
sign off the plan as sound okay and do
you challenge that
conclusion uh no I can I can see what
the council were trying to achieve uh I
understand and what their aims and
objectives were and and how the policies
are worded accordingly so then if we
just look briefly at compliance with the
development plan
please so compliance with the
development plan policy
S12 on page
18 um is the proposal in one of the most
sustainable locations being the three
main settlements no it isn't no um is it
PDL or growth at the Garden suburb or
the Strategic allocation no it's not um
12 maintain their oral character without
compromising the identity of its
individual settlements looked at this
with Mr milc is there anything that you
wish to add to
that um not specifically I think the
issues were covered I mean I I would
endorse his comments that I I do I don't
believe that there is harm for that
particular strand of of S1 S1
be um I mean okay and then S2 and S8 we
agreed with Mr Coleman that we interpret
and apply together correct um
and uh just in terms of S2 first of all
um any evidence of harm to the spatial
strategy or the ldp approach no I've
seen no evidence that that that we're
any way going to prevent that the
council's preferred locations to come
forward be beyond beyond harm to the
identity of the settlement is there any
land used harm which flows from the
conflict with the spatial strategy
claimed by the council no no there's
no um and then if one looks at policy
S8
um we're located outside the settlement
boundary um in which case there are two
points both of which need to be met um
the first is the intrinsic character and
beauty of the countryside cannot be
adversely impacted upon do you recall I
asked some questions about PPS 7 how
consistent is that approach with what
was forly set out in PPS 7 and
protecting the countryside for its own
sake it it it's it follows the same the
same lead in the sex in the sense that
there is no um flexibility allowed for
um other circumstances to come into play
or other benefits to be taken on board
when looking at judging the the harm to
to the landscape area is that policy
approach consistent with what we see in
paragraph 180 A and B of the nppf which
is drawing a distinction between
designated Landscapes valued Landscapes
but recognizing the intrinsic character
and beauty of the countryside as
appropriate that's correct yes um no
sorry is is is what set out
oh no sorry no is it consistent or not
consistent no it's not consistent with
that okay but but can you but can you
can you understand how the inspector
found the plan sound in circumstances
where he was being told well we don't
need any housing outside settlement
boundaries yes as I said before I can
understand how the policies are working
the where they are given the council's
objectives which were set out some years
ago CA can a scheme of Market housing
ever comply
with the exceptions in policy S8 so
Criterion a to
n unless it's allocated and it's no it
can't can a mixed scheme of market and
affordable housing delivered the
affordable housing being delivered by
the market housing can that comply with
the restrictions not a mixed scheme
because it limit age limits it to rural
exception so whether there is any Market
in there is maybe possible but I think
it's highly unlikely so is there
conflict with S2 and S8 yes there is yes
is there conflict with the development
plan as a whole yes there is yes but in
reaching that conclusion what scope is
there to consider the need for the
housing can you consider or are you
required to consider the need for
housing in reaching the conclusion that
there's conflict with the development
plan no the the the wording of of the
plan and the POC and the policies is
such that it doesn't enable that to
happen happened but clearly the case
officers the case office when looking at
this application then went further went
beyond what was in the policies and did
that very exercise of saying well where
are the harms where are the benefits etc
etc and again I'll wrap these questions
up C can I take account of the
accessibility or the sustainability of
the site the economic benefits the
actual landscape and visual impact or
any form of planning balance in reaching
the conclusion that the proposal is
contrary to the development
plan are they allowed within the Poli no
they're not
no and so does this development plan
allow for a balanced appraisal of this
development strict interpretation no it
doesn't and in terms then of the the
success or the performance of the plan
could you turn to your appendices
please and your appendix one which is
the Emory technical
note
yes and uh if we look at 5.2 on page
15 how successful was the plan in being
able to demonstrate a a 5-year
Supply well it wasn't very successful at
all until um until the uh the situation
changed last
year so they it was getting worse went
from 4.9 down to
3.66 and if one looks at the completions
please on page 11 table
4.1 so what page is that say page
11 uh black 11 yeah yeah sorry table
4.1 yes
so we have um the completions and we
agreed with Mr Coleman that uh
performance was not very good in the
first five years um but then what in
what in fact happens if if we think
about uh March 2020 as being the start
of the pandemic what what actually
happens in terms of delivery during the
years of the
pandemic well it actually improves
and so as to the
contention well well you tell me why was
there such a shortfall in housing uh in
the first five years of the plan and why
do we see if we turn over the page a
9914 unit shortfall against the housing
trajectory what what's the reason well
the reason is that the allocated sites
weren't delivering they were slow in
delivering which I think is is an agreed
position yeah we see that at table 4.3
we see a short fall of 910 on the on the
allocated SES and and and obviously with
the council having a sub fiveyear
position there were Green Field sites on
settlement boundaries were being
submitted at that particular Point
making 30 odd per
uh of the total number of houses coming
forward and I would imagine that they
would be uh reflected in the three years
from 2019 up to 2022 2023 as well yes so
does the performance in the first six
years of the play that being problematic
is can that be explained by the pandemic
no what we then see uh if you turn to
black page 14 table
4.4 Mr Coleman was Keen to point out but
performance has been better more
recently what's the explanation for at
least in part for the better performance
in The Last 5 Years with the um windfall
green Green Field sites coming forward
on on the back of the sub fiveyear
position so if Greenfield sites can come
forward in the
pandemic what what explanation does that
provide that it's the pandemic which is
causing the Strategic allocations not to
come
forward no it's it's the the it was the
it was the allocations themselves which
were delayed in coming forward not not
due to any any particular outside
influence so what we have have then is a
plan which wasn't able to demonstrate a
5-year Supply the minimum requirement of
policy against a minimum housing
requirement yes a shortfall against the
minimum annual housing requirement yes
and a very significant shortfall against
the housing trajectory correct and
delivery being propped up by Green Field
sites outside settlement boundaries
correct pause there how
successful has the plan been been to
date I I think that the plan has failed
at this particular moment in time to
deliver what it should be delivering at
this moment in time and I think Mr
Coleman acknowledged that yesterday that
there is a failure in the plan to
deliver where it should be today I think
the difference between ourselves is Mr
Coleman is hoping that the non non-
delivery of the um allocated sites will
improve to be able to then meet the the
shortfall for the next next few years
I'm I'm not necessarily convinced that
is the case and sites like this are are
are sites which will ensure that the
council are able to deliver what their
aims and objectives were um in the local
plan origin it's obviously that was part
of the thinking why the officers
recommended approval for the site in the
first place okay and and previously then
so two points firstly you you've
previously identified that you agree and
accept that the inspector found the
policies were consistent with the mppf
but the second point is if respectfully
this inspector finds that the policy
approach and the spatial approach is too
restrictive and is failing to deliver as
planned and is therefore failing to meet
minimum needs how consistent is that
planned approach with the mppf
imperative to boost significantly the
supply yes the inspector is perfect
entitled to look at the issues in hand
and actually decide that um whilst this
this there are uh there is some conflict
with the policies the overall benefits
um the material considerations would
wear heavily in favor of this game being
approved okay and we look then at the
statement of Common Ground what's the
agreed position in terms of uh the local
authorities position on the need for a
review and an update of the plan
well they've agreed it and and they are
in the process of starting to do that
review and if we then look please at CD
5.9 so CD
5.9 so so this is the briefing over the
briefing to the overview and scrutiny
committee on fiveyear Supply we looked
at this briefly yesterday could you find
please
5.5 on page eight of 13 sorry did you
say 5 5.9 5.9
sorry y got
that um so paragraph So
5.5 what what is the explanation
provided by this officer as to why the
local Authority has failed to deliver as
has planned and failed to Delver the
minimum housing needs against a minimum
housing requirement yes we went through
them yesterday but the there set out a
series of bullet points here which
explain uh the failings of the plan and
that involves the the lack of windfall
allowance the the wording of the actual
policies themselves the strict
settlement boundaries which basically
squeeze out development opportunities
and the settlement hierarchy which is
out of date uh not rob just enough and
again doesn't reflect what the realities
of the situation is and what suggestion
is there in this report from a technical
officer specifically looking into this
issue in
2022 so just as we're coming out of the
pandemic what suggestion is there that
actually it's all down to the pandemic
there's no reference to that at all
right and so how consistent then is the
analysis in five
.9 with the evidence that we have seen
in terms of delivery at the start of the
plan period yes and then through the
pandemic years yes I I I think the the
findings of this report uh mirror the
findings of of the evidence which we put
forward today in terms of the the
failings of of the report and how it in
essence the the plan unless there there
there are
changes uh and applications are dealt
with in a different
way uh certainly this policy officer was
of the view that the plan wasn't going
to deliver and obviously that then um
fed through to the DM officers when they
were writing their report recommending
approval on this
application uh material considerations
please the first one need for Market
housing we agree a 5.97 year Supply
correct correct if you turn in your
appendix please to
to page
21 we see that that is a
supply of
yes of which 620 dwellings this is
533 620 dwellings
37% MH are windfall sites correct so how
consistent is the current component of
the uh 5year Supply with the
plan uh well it's it's it's inconsistent
as as it's it's relying on
non-identified sites to come forward to
top up the supply and if you turn on
please to
5.35 we see that
523 units
31% of the supply are on windfall sites
located outside the settlement boundary
so why is it that this Lo local
Authority can
demonstrate uh a 5year supply at the
moment as a direct result of the
windfall sites being being
approved and if one looks then please at
table
5.5
yes um if we if we just look this is the
future five-year housing land Supply
position based on the council's
trajectory do you see that yes if you
just look back at table 5.3 on page
21 do you see the council's position was
6.67 years correct okay we we we now
agree it's 5.97 so in fact the starting
point should be 5.97 not 6.67 but it
doesn't matter for the for the the broad
point
is based on the council's trajectory
what is going to happen to their supply
of housing it's going to reduce so they
they've had their opportunity via the uh
re um the five fiveyear Supply and the
change to the housing requirement to
279 that obviously improv matters in a
short term way but um what this plan is
showing is that the housing numbers will
then start to
reduce um and then 6.1 then this is the
supply across the plan
period we agreed yesterday a residual of
1969 to
2029 from which we deduct the
1665 to get a residual of
304 so 304 homes still need yeah to be
delivered between now and
2029 yes what does the local Authority
need to do to meet that minimum
requirement to meet minimum economic
housing needs what does it need to do I
think they've got to take some
proactive proactive stance to um change
the way they deliver their housing
numbers but where where are they
consistent with what has happened
through the pandemic years consistent
with the components of the existing
5-year Supply where are those sites
going to have to be consented I think
where appropriate um Green Field sites
come along long then the council need to
take a proactive view on on considering
approving those to further improve their
supply because clearly that was again uh
one of the comments on the uh from the
scrutiny committee
was clearly you need to keep adding
adding to the supply to ensure that
you're able to keep that Supply at the
at the level where it should be so it
needs to be more proactive based on the
on the the experiences which are set out
in this note and in the rest of our
evidence there's a clear pattern for
this particular local Authority and I
believe officers are aware of that and
are trying to put that right and are
trying to improve
it second Point need for affordable
housing large measure of agreed evidence
there is uh evidence of Mr Roberts is
not contested cor um so just looking
then at the the need for affordable
housing what has been delivered I'm not
going to go through this again um what
the future Supply and issues of
affordability how would you characterize
the position in terms of the need for
affordable
housing I I'd categorize it as as acute
a
crisis
whatever the counselor are inevitably
going to fail to deliver what they said
they were going to deliver in terms of
affordable housing
numbers that's not in my mind an
opportunity then to just put your hand
up and say well we're never going to
deliver it therefore we'll just won't do
anything about it um clearly the
evidence we discussed and I don't think
there's anything between ourselves and
Mr Mr colan is is that there is a huge
unmet need out there for all ranges of
of tenure for
affordable uh and it's and it's only
going to get worse I mean you just
listen to the news every day it's going
to get worse and and
to put your hope in the delivery of
these alligated sign
who may come back in and actually look
to reduce the affordable number and that
that has happened on on the larger Urban
extensions in this Authority and other
authorities so they may not actually get
the affordable which they think they're
going to get from the the large Urban
extensions in any event so an
opportunity of a 50% scheme coming
forward uh I I would certainly say
substantial weight is is the minimum
almost to attribute attribute to it yeah
and I think that that's agreed third
issue the need for specialist
accommodation for older people you you
set out uh at your
5.24 the PPG says the need is critical
yes and we looked yesterday at CD 4.2
which is the local authorities SPD which
categorizes the need as being acute yes
and accepts at 226 that Bungalows can
meet those needs so what weight do you
attach to the benefits of meeting the
acute needs of older
people yes again I I I I would say that
that's a um a significant weight to be
attributed to that that provision it's
it's an integral part of affordable
housing open market
housing people moving down downsizing
the whole housing market almost has to
work as one for it to be working as
efficiently it can
be um next please accessibility of the
site is dealt with with in the statement
of common ground at
8.2 so I want to just ask you a couple
of questions about the sustainability of
the
settlement um let's start please with
firstly CD
5.6 at 5.10 so CD 5.6 at
5.10 what conclusion does the council's
latest
evidence reach as to the categorization
of latchington
yes the the recommendation is that it
moves into the category of large Village
from from a small village and it's the
uh the the fourth most sustainable one
and we we see the reasons for that set
out in the table correct what weight do
you say should be attached to this
analysis as as a as an objective piece
of evidence to inform decision making um
I I think background evidence um I I
heard what Mr Coleman had to say um but
background evidence is is a material
consideration it's produced to inform
not only the local plan but it's also
there to inform decisions on planning
applications because clearly the
officers when they made the
recommendation would have been aware of
what what the future of latchington
could be and the failings of the of the
local plan otherwise it wouldn't have
come up with the recommendation which
they came up with and what weight do you
then attach to it uh I'd I'd offer it
I'd suggest has some significant weight
in terms of the consideration of the of
applications not just this one but any
ones which are are are falling within
sustainable locations and then I won't
turn it up it's CD 5.2 page 22 the
issues and options document in the light
of that document what did the council
resolve to do in terms of the position
of latchingdon in the emerging
hierarchy well they proposed to to
upgrade it to the large Village so does
the council as a whole accept the
conclusions of that evidence-based
assessment yes they do yes um next
please in your evidence at
we then have the Healer
assessment so it's your 550 on page
45 what conclusion is reached about the
suitability of the
site uh the suitability is that they
believe the site is a deliverable site
uh they believe it is a sustainable site
and it is has um easy access or
accessibility to to the local
facilities would they Sorry Mr I I I'm
which page were you referring sorry it's
it's Mr Armstrong's 550 on page 45 of
the main proof y 550 got that thank you
and sorry we we looked at this briefly
yesterday P page 46 you've got the
summaries of ld4 and ld6 it was looked
at at two Parcels you've highlighted the
relevant sections overall both Parcels
were considered suitable
um would your view because Mr Coleman's
view appeared to be well that that
doesn't necessarily mean that
latchingdon itself was considered to be
a sustainable settlement do you agree or
disagree with him on that
point
um the the way uh the way I read healers
is that clearly if a site if a village
was
unsustainable then that would be the
findings of the Healer in in essence
saying this is in the village which
would then be suitable for more housing
growth it goes beyond this it
acknowledges that this is a uh a site
with access to sustainable facilities
and concludes that that both both
elements of the site could come forward
uh for housing in the future I I accept
what Mr Colman says this isn't an
allocation but it again it's part of the
background evidence which uh local
uh will take account of and also the the
DM officers will do as well uh next then
fourth point the officer report CD
2.1 so CD 2.1 yes page 8 of 46 at
4.1.7 yes
um what conclusion is reached there by
the officer about the sustainability of
the
settlement well it concludes that it is
sustainable it it it starts with the
smaller Village
allocation then
reviews uh the services in latchington
and considers it to be a sustainable
settlement for further development so
and soor that's a paragraph 4 . 1.7
4.1.7 right yep and if one then just
looks at the next paragraph at
4.1.8 taking into account the
observations made by the two inspectors
in allowing appeals for residential next
to the site at Beach Drive and based on
the information the site is considered
to be a sustainable location for for new
housing so just pausing there we have an
upto-date objective
assessment undertaken by Council
officers to inform decision making mhm
we have technical officers undertaking
the hear we have the officer's report
and then we have the council
accepting the conclusions of the
objective assessment and resolving to
upgrade as you say latchington as a
larger Village and then we have the
inspector's decisions yes so what when
do you
attach to that consensus of evidence
that latchington is a sustainable
settlement for further growth I think
it's it's it's a significant body of of
evidence it's not just one one report or
or one note it's actually a um a series
of reports and and obviously those
appeal decisions date from
201415 so there were some years ago and
even at that stage the inspector
inspectors were happy to endorse
latchington as a sustainable
location and um if we just turn please
to CD
8.4 I'm not sure I've got the right note
yes so CD 8.4 sorry CD
8.4
and do you recall that the point was
made by Mr Coleman well some of those
decisions were made in circumstances
where there wasn't a 5year supply and I
took him to Mr um pof's evidence which
suggested that wasn't right I just want
to look at this one decision so decision
of Inspector Bard made on the 10th of
September 2015 do you have that I have
yes and so this is in respect of land to
the east of Burnham Road latchington
and we see that this is the application
for um I think it's the 44 unit scheme
is that right that's correct yes and if
you could just turn please to paragraph
14 what in fact was the basis of the
decision in respect of whether there was
a 5year supply the inspector doesn't
rule either way he feels that the sche
as he says I found the scheme would not
harm the character and appearance of the
area and then concludes in paragraph 15
it would be consistent with the
framework clearly the previous version
not conflict with the policies but
previous but nonetheless it would be a
compatible
scheme which would not harm the
landscape character so that that
decision was not predicated on the
fiveyear supply it was predicated on a a
flat
balance assessment of the evidence
before the inspector at that
time uh next please economic role we
agreed significant weight with Mr
Coleman which just leaves the
environmental um benefits I'm not going
back on the identity of latchington
Point um the public open space we know
what's being provided you've dealt with
how it can be secured through the
reserve matters what waight to the
benefits to existing and proposed
residents of the 4.2 hectares of formal
and informal public open
space
um I think we're talking about a a
significant
benefit um and that's backed up by
obviously the green infrastructure
strategy which we went through
yesterday um but there was also some
comments from the the parish council
which perhaps I can just refer to um in
their comments to
the planning
application I don't know what CD
reference that is I'm afraid but
um it was a response to the outline
planning
application from the parish
council I don't know whether you've got
that sir I um I I don't have it it's
comments on the planning applic so
you're talking about their consultation
consultation response I think it might
be if you want to look at the back of CD
2.1 I think the consultation responses
are summarized at the end of the officer
report
yes well I've I've got the sort of the
the um full version and I just wanted to
point
out um the comments of the parish
council and I'll just I'll read them out
so that's probably easiest thing to do
in terms of open space uh it says it
should be noted that latchington has
less recreational space than the 6 acre
standard and whilst this is an increase
in space it will not reduce the overall
deficiency because it's separate and
segregated so basically they're saying
it's too far away to actually have any
benefit that that's obviously a decision
for you to decide so whether it is or
whether it isn't but nonetheless they've
accepted that there's a shortage of
recreational space in latchington at the
moment
and the second comment to policy
E3 is it should be noted that lington
has extremely limited and old children's
play
facilities there is also an absence
absence of any youth amenity or
infrastructure and this is a major area
of
concern so there I appreciate I'm I'm
not trying to suggest the parish are
supporting the scheme in any way but
they've Honestly made it clear that the
open space base which was discussed as
part of the the um pre-application
discussion will actually meet an
identified need in the Aira that's a
need identified by both the parish and
the authors of the the green
infrastructure note as well I'm not sure
not sure that's captured in the summary
no it's not sir I mean as you say as you
fairly point out uh Mr Armstrong um they
obviously object to the proposal but uh
um yeah I I think the summary in the the
officer report doesn't actually pick
that up so I I I mean it might be useful
to have a you know have that uploaded as
a as
a either an inquiry document or or a
core
document if it's not already no I don't
I don't think it is so so we can do it
might be useful to to have that provided
given that you've referred to it Mr
Armstrong I I'll leave it out for
okay so significant weight to the public
open space and then uh
biodiversity net
gain um if you look at the statement of
common ground at 816 don't need to turn
it up it's a matter of common ground
that it would result in a significant
net gain in biodiversity is that correct
that's correct yes okay and which we've
given moderate
weight to that benefit moderate weight
moderate weight yes and so just
drawing the threads together then so
you've identified the conflict with the
development plan you've identified the
material considerations what why do you
say in this case the material
consideration should outweigh the
conflict with the development plan um
for two reasons I think one is is
clearly the failure of the plan to to
deliver where it should be at this
particular stage of its of its
life um the unquestionable need for
Market housing as a result of that and
affordable housing as
well and then the the the benefits which
the scheme is offering over and above
the sort of benefits which you would
normally expect to see developed with a
with a scheme so the increase in the
affordable the increase in the
biodiversity the uh three times amount
of open space that we would normally
provide which is clearly meeting an
identified
need so there there are there are
significant material
considerations to take on board when
compared with the with the breaches of
the policies which we've been through at
length which for one of a better phrase
I I I classify as technical rather than
substantive that's for discussion and I
think on that basis I think the um
pendulum swings in favor um and and
that's exactly what the the officers did
when they wrote their committee report I
mean I think
the fact that that officer's report was
written
positively is a is a is a is something I
haven't come across for a long time and
just to be clear on that I'll lead on
some of these points but it was written
positively in the context of a higher
housing land Supply than we've agreed
yes a lower level of affordable housing
and a lower level of bungalow provision
that's correct so well leave can make of
that what he want but in in in light of
the the issues for an officer officers
to write such a positive flat balanced
application in in
in in these times for one of a bit of
phrase um the officers were clearly of a
view that this that this site and sites
like it should come
forward and and they stood up and
defended their position in this room
with members who
who unanimous unanimously did not like
what was presented to them which is why
we're here today but officers defended
their position as best they could and
presented the case as best they could
and I think that that is is um fairly
unique position which I think reflects
the position the council find themselves
in thank you sir my questions thank you
Mr thank you very much Mr kuk um we
could take a short uh break now um
before you start your cross- examination
uh Mr Wilcox roughly how long do you
think you you might be I think I will
be
around about an hour and a half right
okay well let's just have a a short
break now um and we'll come back at um
it's now nearly 20 past two so if we
come back at um at
25-3 that's okay yeah thank you you
now
transition and you will now onar the
live stream
right well good afternoon everybody
we'll resume the public inquiry we've uh
we're now at the stage where um the uh
appellant witness will be um
cross-examined by Mr Willcox of the
council uh so I'll allow Mr Wilcox to
start his
questioning thank you very much sir and
good afternoon Mr Armstrong afternoon
I'd like to begin please with the the
really really big picture point about
the the the balancing exercise which the
inspector's required to undertake here
as we all know section 386 is the
legislative framework starting point is
the development plan where there's
compliance you usually follow where
there's non-compliance you follow to a
other refusal and L material
considerations in the otherwise so far
so good to good yes uh there's nothing
flat is there about the section 386
balance it is tilted firmly in favor of
the answer given by the development plan
yes your starting point is the
development plan that's right and that's
recognized in the mppf as well paragraph
12 yes correct and it's a particularly
powerful presumption isn't it because it
doesn't flow from policy but from law
it's a statutary presumption that's
correct thank you and you confirmed in
Chief very helpfully that you accept
conflict with the development plan
overall in this case I do as I explained
that as how I see that yes as you
explained you also accept and this is in
your proof it's it's a basic point so I
don't think we need to turn it up you
accept that the mppf Tilted balance the
paragraph 11 tilted balance is not
engaged yeah that's correct that's
correct as we know there are three ways
in which the Tilted balance can be
engaged the most important policies can
be out of date or you cannot have a
fiveyear land Supply or your housing
delivery test score can be below 75% in
essence for this sort of proposal
correct yes uh you accept tilted balance
isn't engag which means you accept that
none of those three triggers apply
that's correct thank you let's have a
look at the development plan itself
please called document
3.1 now you make a point in your proof
which is that your your assessment of S1
non-compliance effectively flows from
your conclusions on S2 and S8 so what
we'll do is we'll come to S1 last okay I
think uh let's start please page
17 uh policy
S2 which is our strategic growth policy
as we
know that policy establishes and gives
effect the housing allocations
neighborhood plan allocations of wifall
allowances effectively as the sources of
future delivery doesn't it that's
correct yes it directs developments to
those places which was judged by the
democratically elected councilors of the
district to be most appropriate at the
time that it was approved it does indeed
yes that's right and it's Common Ground
isn't it the site isn't within any of
those identified sources that's correct
hence our conflict with S2 which you
accept correct policy S8 next please
which is page
45 now we haven't dwelt yet on the
supporting text which precedes the
policy it's worth just having a a little
look at
2.100 and
2.11 what these do uh Mr Armstrong is
they establish broadly two functions for
policy sa don't they function one is it
helps to inform neighborhood Planning
and Development control
decisions which is what two 100 tells
uses yes and number two is it provides
further clarification as it puts it in
terms of the types of development that
may be more suitably located in the
countryside with reference to other ldp
policies So that's its second function
do you see that as well yes I do
yes and it's in that
context that we need to have a look at
what the policy says about development
in the countryside that we know it tells
us the countryside will be protected for
its landscape natural resources
ecological value and its intrinsic
character and
beauty and it then sets out the two-part
test for development Beyond settlement
boundaries doesn't it one intrinsic
character and beauty of the countryside
not adversely
impacted yes and two there's then the
list of development types which are
acceptable yes yeah it's a long list
isn't it is the long list of things
which are acceptable Beyond boundaries
that
includes residential development doesn't
it we can see Lim G Agricultural and an
essential workers accommodation
yeah I that would produce a very
limited number of of dwellings but yes
and I would expect to see that there in
any event y similarly we expect to see
royal exception sites and we find them
at H yes yeah and it's worth noting M as
well other proposals in compliance with
ldp policies neighborhood plans and
other local planning guidance and that
could at least theoretically include
housing couldn't it if it was allocated
by a neighborhood
plan well you would then have to go back
to policy S1 and S2 would you which
which we're going to do we're going to
which and and and the absolute reading
of these policies is that you wouldn't
get past S1 and S2 unless you were in
unless you're in allocated site wind for
sight or neighborhood plan site and of
course a neighborhood plan site would be
entirely consistent with M wouldn't it
because it reflects neighborhood plan
allocations now you've described the
effect of this Countryside policy in
various ways in your proof we we have
have um noteworthy expressions like a
ring of Steel around developments and no
flexibility for change very limited if
any development outside of the
boundaries those expressions you I'm
sure recall yeah yes
absolutely but of course as we've seen
from the long
list of development types which are
acceptable there's no ring of steel or
anything like that here at all is there
Mr Armstrong what's happened is that the
proposal the policy forgive me sets up a
significant number of types of
development which are acceptable the
problem is that your client's type of
development isn't on the
list that's not the same thing as a ring
of Steel at all is it no I think it is a
it is a a ring of Steel whether my view
of it would would be the same whether
we've got a scheme or not it it limits
the opportunities for sites which don't
fall within the categories to come
forward and that clearly includes
housing uh most of those uh criteria
there include there are long-standing
uses appropriate
for use in the in the open Countryside
so there's nothing it's not introducing
anything new or or or wizzy all those
things have been around for some time so
it's not offering that opportunity for a
balanced review of whether or not a
housing site for example can be
considered suitable based on the uh
material considerations and the benefits
flowing from it which clearly is what
the mppf is now suggesting we do well
we're going to revisit that point when
we look at S1 if that's okay but for now
on the idea of the restrictiveness of
the policy it's a a a point you made in
Chief and which you Al make in your
proof is is your your suggestion that
the restrictive nature of the policy is
such that it's inconsistent with par
180b of the mppf which has shifted yes
the the old PPS 7 language of protect
the country sides the new language of
recognized intrinsic character and
Beauty that's correct yes I'd like to
have a look with you please at what the
examining inspector said about that in
the course of examining this local plan
and for that can we please take up core
document 3
16 yep and we're going to go to PDF and
hard copy
page
please sorry we'll go one above we'll go
to 22 initially 22 Yeah and we'll see
there's a heading issue two do you have
that got that and issue two about
settlement hierarchy we can see from the
very first words of paragraph 115 that
this is all about policy
S8 the inspector goes on to uh to
describe what the policy is
doing reaching the point in 118 of
noting that the policy sets out a
coherent hierarchy of settlements do you
see that I do yeah
it's then discussion about attempts to
move placing of settlements within the
hierarchy one way or another some
seeking alterations to settlement
boundaries all the kind of things that
we know go on all the time in
examinations in
public some
suggestions and the inspector R say
Clarity rejected all of those at the end
of the paragraph 120 some suggestions
about correcting errors which is quite a
discret point and then at 121 we get
this about S8 this is not as some appear
to suggest a blanket ban on Royal
development describes new windfall
housing is permitted within the
settlement boundaries list of
development types allowed outside the
boundaries is not overly stringent
describes all the things it does all of
the uses supported outside the
settlement boundaries are in my view
appropriate and consistent with
paragraph 28 of the framework and then
we get an important sentence here indeed
I consider the approach taken by policy
sa to be consistent with the framework's
core planning principles it strikes a
suitable balance between
recognizing the intrinsic character and
beauty of the countryside and supporting
the thriving rural communities within it
do you see that yes so the examining
inspector when he was considering the
compliance of S8 with the
mppf was very much not applying the old
PPS 7 approach was he he was applying
the mppf approach as it was in 2012 and
as it is now Rec ignition not protection
do you
see yes I see that and the inspector's
conclusion in respect of whether S8 was
consistent with the framework
recognition of intrinsic character and
Beauty was that it was wasn't
it yes I'm I'm just the way I read that
is clearly the inspector was being
presented with a certain strategy by the
local
Authority which was very specific about
how to deliver their housing
requirements
there was no leeway other than the way
that the local plan sets it out so in
which
case the inspector was then asked to
basically draw uh a ring of Steel around
the various policies to ensure that
those policies are
delivered so what he's saying is what
what's being presented to me which is
S8 I'm happy
with because those us named within it
are the sort of uses you would you would
normally accept in the open Countryside
so he's got no problem with those
uses um and he's considering those uses
as being the ones which then uh strike a
suitable balance between the intrinsic
character but clearly at the beginning
he's been told that new windfall Market
housing is permitted only within
settlement boundary so that he's been
told that the council are not going to
look for Market housing in in the open
Countryside as part of their strategy
he's been told that and he's regarded
that as acceptable and consistent with
the framework on on yes on the basis of
the strategy being presented to him by
by the local Authority for them to be
able to focus the development in the
three key
towns what they want is for developers
to focus there rather than necessarily
in Green Field sites and that's so I
understand why they're doing it and he's
gone along with their their case clearly
what we're looking at now is the situ
ation which hasn't arrived if the
inspector hadn't liked their case he may
well have said that he wanted more
flexibility for sites in in in Green in
Greenfield locations to conford but he
didn't because that wasn't what was
presented to him the the difficulty with
all of that Mr Armstrong is that your
fundamental criticism of S8 is that it
it's that it seeks to protect rather
than to recognize intrinsic character
and beauty and that's true whatever your
strategy is isn't it that that's a point
about the structure of S8 itself about
its absence of as you would put it
inbuilt flexibility yeah that's true but
and the inspector didn't sorry sorry
that's true sorry to interrupt but I
think in this instance there was a very
specific strategy which was been
presented to the inspector had the
inspector been worried about the council
delivering the inspector May well have
looked at having the a more flexible
approach to sites in the open
Countryside on on the way that the mppf
says set today at the moment
so inspectors are there to to to help
and support local authorities deliver
their local plans to respond to their
strategies they're not there to make the
strategies up there saying is it sound
is it moving in the right direction how
do I how do I need to set those policies
up to make those strategies work yes
that's and that's what he's responding
to here that's what he's responding to
and a part of his job in doing that
response is to test what's being
proposed against consistency with the
framework he tested S as structured
against the framework and he found it to
be acceptable as as presented to him as
part of this appeal and finally the
inspector didn't have car blanch to say
actually I think the wording of sh
should be should be made wider because
that's what the mppf says it should be
he is looking at the strategy in front
of him at that particular moment final
point for the sake of completeness on
all of this is uh paragraph
124 conclud on issue two considering the
above with the main modification put
forward by the council and as discussed
and that was adding in the wording to
2.100 which we saw I conclude the
settlement hierarchy and the plans
approach to settlement boundaries and
the countryside and the countryside are
Justified effective consistent with
national poity and positively prepared
did you see that I do see that yes thank
you now having done that um I hope
fairly brief and painless caner through
those two policies we can now return to
S1
please which we find at page
15 just going to find my own there we
go sorry forgive me it's page 14
electronically isn't it there we
go so page 14 we know don't we this is
the overarching sustainability policy
for the whole plan
so do you have it I can't
count is it 40 I've I've got 14 yeah one
14 one 14 the
PDF I've got a hard copy here so don't
worry that's fine but yeah if you're use
it's page 14 in the hard copy as well
happily S1 yes go s one S1 you have it
so this this is the S overarching
sustainable development policy of the
we're all familiar with yeah and we know
it's important I think just to to dwell
for a moment on the whole structure of
the policy we know that it suggests a
positive approach towards development
reflecting the presumption in favor of
sustainable development in the mppf sets
up the key principles in policy and
decision making we've got 2 three and 12
which will return to in a moment but in
terms of the overarching structure we
need to carry on to the next page don't
we where we find this within the policy
box that planning applications that
Accord with the policies in the ldp and
where relevant neighborhood plans will
be approved unless material
considerations indicate otherwise you
see that that's reflecting what we would
Now call mppf 11c yes and then we have
this where there are no policies
relevant to the application or relevant
policies are out of date at the time of
making the decision the council will
grant permission unless material
considerations indicate otherwise do you
see that
this is
effectively bringing the mppf Tilted
balance and its triggers into the
development plan itself yes you see that
I do and that's important isn't it for
assessing the flexibility of the plan as
a
whole because what it means is this when
we when you suggest that there are uh
there are severe or Ring Of Steel type
restrictions within S8 the development
plan
itself only applies those restrictions
where you have a fiveyear housing land
Supply and where your housing delivery
test results are above 75% doesn't it
yes in the event that you have a failure
of Supply in Falling below five years or
you have a failure of delivery in it
falling below
75% then this final par paragraph of S1
effectively switches off S8 doesn't
it uh it reduces the weight of S8 yeah
it doesn't switch it off but it reduces
no the development plan contains a
policy which tells you yes what to do in
that situation so and clearly there were
a lot of Green Field sites were were
approved through that mechanism when the
Tilted balance was was in play for the
applications we talked about earlier
that's right so there's your
flexibility there's your flexibility you
have flexibility when the
mf's mechanisms for identifying housing
delivery or Supply
problems would bring the Tilted balance
into play and it's Common Ground between
us isn't it that the mppf mechanisms
aren't in play in this case that's
correct so the reason that S8 applies in
the protective way that it does
is because on mppf terms there isn't a
problem in this district with Supply or
delivery of
housing well that's perhaps where we
might
disagree well well let's let's think
about what the mppf tells us there I
mean the the mppf gives us a whole
series of mechanisms doesn't it with a
whole series of consequences beginning
on the supply side we can turn it up if
we need to but this this I'm sure would
be bread and butter to both of us on the
supply side we have your 5 years Supply
position yes if you have more than 5
years tilted balance isn't engaged yeah
if you have less the Tilted balance is
engaged so that's a supply side
mechanism for tweaking weight yeah yes
on the delivery side we have paragraph
79 yes which again we can turn up if
need be I'm sure I'm happy I I think the
difference here is clearly the flat
balance argument which we're talking
about today and clearly the officers
grappled with with when they when they
prepared their committee reports that
this doesn't consider the flat balance
being uh an option moving
forward it it allows development to come
forward under the circumstances you've
explained and I agree with you on that
they are the obvious reasons for sites
uh for applications to come forward but
they're not the only ones the flat
balance is always there material
considerations are always available and
the background evidence and the waiting
of those material consider
considerations should then be uh weighed
in in favor of a scheme coming forward
on that basis which is exactly what
professional planning officers did when
they made the committee report but of
course there more than I think use the
term obvious uh obvious reasons why it'
be triggered the the 5year supply and
75% HDT mechanisms they're not obvious
they're the ones that the central
government has told us to in terms of
how this all works aren't they yeah okay
obvious is perhaps a wrong word but they
are the the sort of the standard
approaches yeah they're the ones
mandated by by national policy yes I I
accept that and and I accept that the
policies as worded given the significant
number of Green Field sites which have
been approved through that mechanism I
understand that officers and members
have dealt with that through that
particular process we're going through a
different process here and that's where
the working of these policies becomes
somewhat um difficult and Troublesome in
when you're trying to do that balancing
exercise
well you you say you say Troublesome Mr
Armstrong I'm going to press you a
little on that there's there's nothing
Troublesome is there about policies
seeking to direct development in
particular directions the directions
democratically approved by the elected
members in circumstances where both
Supply and delivery are healthy in mppf
terms yes if the plan is delivering as
per the policies which we measure by
reference to the HDT and the land that's
one there are ways of measuring it there
are other ways of measuring it as well I
mean there are as we've discussed today
internal reviews done by the local
Authority themselves which criticize the
plan not being fit fit for purpose the
evidence base shows that uh the delivery
of where we should be today hasn't been
achieved so therefore it's not fit for
purpose on that front so the plan
shouldn't it shouldn't be stuck repeat
repeat repeat when the outcomes of of
those policies are in themselves not
delivering and again I I'll don't labor
the point with you but the
the the the the point between us is in
what not delivering means in this
context isn't it because if you measure
whether it's delivering or Not by
reference to whether it is meeting or
failing the mppf tests for delivery then
this plan is doing fine it's got almost
six years land Supply and
155% H DT score against those tests
we're not challenging on that the it's
the other areas where we are at OD with
you the difference between us myself Mr
Coleman is that Mr colan is keeping his
fingers crossed that the
permitted uh consense which are right
there will suddenly start to deliver and
and get the council out of a hall well
we don't think that is the case I and I
understand that's the point between you
we'll return to that a little bit later
on within S1 I promised I'd come back to
the list of key principles and now's the
moment when we're going to do so um you
accept don't you that the proposal
breaches key principle to it's
not uh a sustainable level of housing
growth that will meet local needs and
deliver a wide choice of high quality
homes in the most sustainable locations
because of the S2 Bridge yes I
appreciate you described that as
technical but yes it's it's a conflict
isn't it it's it's a conflict on the on
the use of the word most sustainable
locations which are defined as your
three main towns
yeah that's right uh number three
similar Point effective use of land and
prioritized development on PDL and plan
growth in Garden sou strategic
allocations again because of the result
of the S2 question we have a breach here
as well correct Y and on point 12 rural
character of The District without
compromising the identity of its
individual
settlements uh can can I take it that if
the inspector is against Mr milc and his
evidence he's also going to be against
you in your evidence on this point I
don't need to repeat my questions no I
think I think both of us see see the
issues very in very similar ways yes
yeah that's that's that's what I hope I
hoped you are going to say there is one
point however which needs to be picked
up with you I think on this question
which emerged from Mr mist's
reexamination which of course I don't
have a reply to you you recall we were
looking at the characterization
assessment with Mr mil yes and you'll
recall he was asked some questions about
which was worse out of a nucleated
development form or expanding the ribbon
as it were he he
identified what he thought would be a
more severe landscape and visual
implications from lengthening ribbon
development you remember that yes and
you'll also remember the questions I put
to him about the problems with nucleated
development which that document
identifies yeah so you're effectively
stuck between the devil and the deep
blue sea with this aren't you where you
expand them in a nucleated way you lose
the linear character and you expand them
in a ribbon fashion and you're going to
create a adverse landscape and visual
impact you see that point yes yeah that
is a very very good reason indeed isn't
it to impose strict controls on
development Beyond settlement boundaries
for this kind of settlement because
however you develop them you're going to
cause a problem aren't you you're either
going to impact on the agricultural
character of the settlements or or you
going to create an lvia issue from
lengthening the ribbon along the road
there'll be
change and the key to it is the extent
of that change and the specifics of the
village in
question uh I think it's Mr mrie was
explaining is that latchington uh being
one of the larger
Villages not as defined yet but being
one of the larger Villages um had a a a
smaller linear Cor
and from the 60s onwards was already
expanding
[Music]
outwards okay so so so in terms of
deciding whether or not preservation
needed to take place it wasn't the type
of village for example some of the
smaller Villages where development has
has effectively Stood Still for for many
many years the linear pattern is still
very obvious to everybody and any
development which had to come along
clear the starting point would be it
should be in cartic with the area you
may obviously find these Villages are in
conservation areas as well and there are
Village plans or whatever it is to
protect these particular characters no
such preservation or or or character
exists in lington and what we've seen
over time is that lington has
consistently expanded away from the
linear
pattern there's 162 houses of being have
being built in lington majority of those
are are not in the linear
form um so the character of the area is
already mixed for want of a better
phrase there is no strong linear pattern
what remains of it is obviously the road
pattern and the network and those
properties which do front onto those
roads um but you've now now got a
significant increase which is just is
more nuclear in in pattern and actually
sits very well with with the the older
part of of latchington and they were
obviously approved at local level and
approved at appeal and the issue of
linear linear development has never come
up in any of the the decisions or the
issues uh which I can see from from
other
schemes well as you've the inspector's
heard my questions to Mr milr has heard
your answer I'm not going to go over all
of that with you again as you well know
we on this side of the table don't
accept that analysis but
I we're not going to go through it all
again that's fine uh so we've got
conflicts with key principle 2 3 and 12
you accept don't you that sufficient to
create a conflict with S1
overall I do yes that thank you and S1
S2 and S8 combined are weighty enough to
result in development plan conflict
overall yeah which we've established at
the
outset thank you and I'm glad to say
we're making much better progress than I
thought we would so so we may be
finished even sooner than I'd anticip
ipated which I'm sure we'll all be all
be grateful for won't we um turning then
to some material considerations points
with you uh Mr Armstrong you'll be glad
to know I'm not going to go through each
and every difference in Waiting between
you and Mr Coleman I don't think the
inspector would thank me for it and I
don't think he'd be helped by it so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to focus
just on a few of them where there are
there are key points of differ and I'd
like to begin please with the market
housing position
mm
now we all agree five years isn't a cap
in Supply terms and I'm not going to
suggest you for a moment that housing
doesn't carry weight if you have more
than five years Supply you that would
not be something I would Advance it's
not something that anyone can sustain
but it's inevitably the case isn't it
that the weight to be attached to Market
housing provision
will go down where the supply position
goes up better the supply less weight to
new houses yes as as a general theme I
would agree agree with you on that okay
and we've already had a bit of a think
about how the mppf measures these
questions haven't we yes uh the mppf is
as we all know the central government's
mandated approach to how we deal with
questions both of plan making and
decision taking very powerful material
consideration we all know yes and the
tests which it
establish excuse me which it
establishes are the Tilted balance for
Supply yes and a tiered series of more
and more severe consequences for an
authority depending on the level to
which it fails it's HDT yes y yeah yes
so if your HDT is 95% you need an action
plan if it drops to 85% you need an
action plan plus a 20% buffer on your
your land Supply 75% it's those two
things plus you're within the Tilted
balance yes yeah yes so and that that is
a graded test that's been considered by
national policy isn't it correct and the
the yard stick which it uses to measure
suitability of delivery rates and to
apply that graded sequence of uh of
ramifications is the HDT which is
broadly speaking your uh delary rates
over the previous three years you aware
of that yes yes I'm aware of that yes
yeah now that being so it's important
isn't it in this case to uh to look at
the agreed numbers you know it is Common
Ground here that our HDT score is
155% isn't it it is yes correct in other
words over the last three years over the
period the mppf tells us to think about
there's an overd delivery of housing in
this Burrow under the HDT yes the H
which correct is what central government
has said to look at it yes it's it's
it's a tool to be used for that purpose
yes correct yeah in fact it's the tool
to be used for that purpose in the mppf
isn't it in terms of the mppf sub five
years in HDT are are the tools to they
are the tools not exclusive but they are
the tools which your starting point is y
and as we've as we've said on housing
land Supply we're at 5.97 so not not
even marginal well above the point at
which the tiled balance fires isn't
it what that means therefore Mr
Armstrong is that on the detailed
structured gradated approach of the
mppf there's no need is there to disturb
the development plan position in molden
as a result of Market housing name
that's correct if if you stop at that
particular Point clearly we've gone
beyond that and we've looked to S see
what sits behind the council's delivery
of their housing numbers through their
local plan and I think that we see a a
problem which is
not part of the mppf tool tools but is a
matter which we believe is is
significant for the flat balance
consideration for this particular scheme
you say you say flat balance I think we
we agreed earlier we're in a we're in a
section 386 tilted balance aren't we as
it were where by by flat you mean MP PF
tilted balance not engaged correct yes
yeah okay you accept don't you that
there's a presumption in favor of
refusal in this case no because of the
development plan conflict I'm not going
over that it's no that's fine I just
wanted to make sure we were all clear
yeah no no no the material it's the
materials considerations and
circumstances which is the the area
which we're looking at that's great
um just a very very little bit I'm
you'll be glad to know I'm not going to
get into a lot of numbers with you but I
do want want to take a brief look please
at the most recent AMR for the district
which is called document 3.3
please just find it
myself there we
go and this I'm sure is a document that
you're familiar with yourself we went we
went through it with this has been this
has been seen with Mr Coleman yeah and
we not don't we in table one that
the shortfall for each year is shown
there we're in a total sort of net
shortfall as it were across the plan
period of 109 dwellings correct that's
agre Y and then table
two shows us the position on the
allocations do you have table two I have
yes great and Mr Coleman was right
wasn't he to point out that as things
stand at the AMR base date there is
plenty of headro for future delivery in
these allocations isn't there if we look
for instance
at uh if we look for instance at
s2d that's got
1,138 uh capacity within the planning
permission which hasn't started
delivering yet at all so all of that
delivery is going to be future loaded
isn't it I agree there HED room what
what worries me more what is that uh 480
of those should have been delivered by
22 23 and they haven't nothing's been
delivered and I think that that that's
the substantial issue between us is is
the optimism which uh Mr Coleman is
looking at that table I'm looking at in
a more realistic fashion thinking
there's only 38% of the sites
delivered we look to date sorry that's
fine I didn't want to cut across you I
thought you were finished if we look at
s2a for instance which is I think
another one the the other end of the
garden suburbs isn't it I can't remember
if it's the North or the South one but
that um on that one we could see we've
got a uh net permission of a thousand
and that one actually is delivering
isn't it I see that one's delivering
some of them some of the Del some of
them are delivering and some of them are
not delivering some of them have got
zeros three three have got uh zeros
against them
and that's that's worrying to my mind
that those sites haven't even started to
deliver
thank you one moment
please yes that's right now
you've dwelt in your evidence and Mr
canet dwelt with Mr Coleman in his
examination on uh the inclusion of
Greenfield sites within the supply
position so far and on the think exactly
the word she used for it but it was
along the along the lines that they this
district has used Green Field sites to
get to the supply position lities yes
now we've got to be wary here haven't we
of a of a logical non Secor even if
there were a case for allowing Green
Field development in this District to
achieve an ongoing healthy Supply
position which we don't accept but even
if that were the case it doesn't follow
does it that this
Green Field site should be delivered we
have to be careful there don't we no I
fully accept it doesn't automatically
followed just because there is a history
of I I you have to look at the in the
site as a as a as a suitable housing
site as well
as yes AB the the overall issue so no I
I I I fully accept that good thank you
and and of course I hope you you'd also
accept that if the inspector agrees with
Mr Coleman and not Mr milc on impact on
settlement identity and Royal character
and things like that and finds that this
scheme would have an adverse impact such
as to engage s112 and that would be a
perfectly good reason wouldn't it for
not choosing this Green Field
site it it would be a matter for the
inspector to add to the the planning
balance and and the conclusion would
then flow from from the exercise the
inspector would then have to
do thank you very much and then we're
actually almost there you'll be glad to
know Mr Armin we've made much better
progress than I thought we would um or
my estimate was wildly off which I think
is probably more realistic you're never
criticized for that no no that's that's
right indeed Mr Mr WL Cox it's much
appreciated your your your you know
Speedy approach well so we we're at the
we're at the point where as is often the
case with the very final witness for the
final main party everyone knows what
what the issues are you won't be
assisted by me inde indeed well thank
you anyway for for everyone's
cooperation thank you absolutely and
with with that in mind I'll move to my
my very final topic which is
environmental benefits I just wanted I I
I was a little bit confused by by the
approach in your proof but I think I
understand it better from Chief so i'
just like to test this now says
paragraph
5.86 you ident ify moderate
weight
to um all positive factors that points
the environmental sustainability of the
scheme and way in its favor I think
based on your evidence in Chief the
moderate weight you assign to the BNG
delivery and you assign significant
weight to things like the open space
delivery is that is that right that's
correct I thought that was the position
I just wanted to check and
understood on the uh the latter of those
two then I'm not going to ask you
anything about B G just just everyone so
everyone knows what we're talking about
we're talking about biod biodiversity
Net game is that that's that's the one
so I'm just aware no no no no I I I I
know we often end up talking our own
language and a lot of people you know
who who might be listening might think
what are all these uh various terms that
we're using but just just to be clear
yeah that's right by there's a there's a
requirement within various National
policies for there to be a B for there
to be a biodiversity net gain so for the
sites to make things better in
biodiversity terms the number which we
often use to assess that is whether it's
more than 10% and in this case this is
more than 10% by quite a way so that's
why there's no dispute about that on the
attachment of significant weight to the
Green Space type of environmental
benefit you've described in your proof
haven't you um the the various benefits
that flow low from the provision of that
um for that green space within your
section on Community Health social and
cultural well-being yes but that benefit
is tempered isn't it by the harm to the
intrinsic character and beauty of the
country side that is going to emerge
from building or one is that present and
undeveloped Green
Space it it's a good thing to have this
this publicly accessible Green Space and
so on but it's also a a bad thing
to be building on fields in the first
place in environmental terms I
understand but I think it's two separate
exercises you look at the scheme as a
whole which includes the open space in
terms of its its impact which I think
we've agreed is it's it's got limited
impact in terms of landscape harm and
we've had the discussion on the category
12 points so I think you look at you
look at the scheme as a whole to start
with and that then you do the assessment
then and then you then go beyond that to
say
if that harm is deemed acceptable which
we say it is it's fairly limited uh then
you then look at say well what other the
benefits then flowing from the from the
scheme itself and we said the open space
has significant
benefit one moment
Mr that yeah I'm not going to do
that lovely Mr Armstrong thank you very
much so those are my questions thank you
Mr Wilcox for for that that's most
helpful um thank you Mr Armstrong I
don't have any specific points um that I
want to put to you
um I think you've Mr uh Wilcox has asked
the mo most most of the questions that I
I was going to put and and I think we've
we' we've had clarification in your um
examination in Chief regarding the issue
of
um securing any Landscaping belt via the
the framework plan I think uh I'm not
sure if the conditions are currently um
framed in that way or not but you you
seem to be happy that that could be an
approach that is adopted we're happy
they're not framed at that way at the
moment sir but we're more than happy for
a condition to require the framework
plan to be this the sort of starting
point for the for any future Reserve
matter yes I mean I don't know
whether we I'm just looking at the list
[Music]
um
I we don't have as far as I can see a a
a a condition that with with plan
numbers on it do we or do we as I said
I've only looked at this in a very
cursory
way because I would have thought we
would
we would need one anyway to you know
just to identify the site yes
yes
um yeah I mean as I say I I was only
supplied with these earlier today so I
haven't really had a chance to go
through them in in detail but I mean
even you know even the most basic
outline scheme you would normally have a
a condition saying you
know identifying the site you know that
that would what would what you would
normally do I think perhaps the thing to
do so is to to pick all this up in the
round table I think so speed to indeed
and and um it also will you know if I if
I um can have the opportunity obviously
to to look through these in more detail
um that would that would be good I as I
I've only looked at them in a very
cursory way so far so
but I I I appreciate your uh
acknowledgement uh Mr Armstrong that
you're you're happy in principle for
that to occur and I should just make it
clear to everyone this is in the event I
was minded to allow the appeal the the
conditions discussion is always part of
the process that we go through and with
these kind of events doesn't mean that
I'm I've made my mind up so thank you
for that Mr Armstrong um Mr kuk do you
have any yes sir just a few points sorry
to prong matters um C can we start
please with do you recall you were asked
about policy
S8 and the inspector's report at 121
yes so CD
316 at paragraph
121 and Mr Wilcox
questions were around and I'm just going
to take you to the last line policy s
strikes a suitable balance between
recognizing the intrinsic character and
beauty of the countryside and supporting
the thrival rural thriving rural
communities within it yes um and your
view please on whether that was a
reasonable conclusion to
reach in
2017 when the case that was being put is
that we can meet market and affordable
housing provision Within locations at
the three main locations your view on
the appropriateness of the conclusion at
that time yeah as I said I think that
that was the inspector's response to
what he was being presented with and and
I understand why the inspector has has
gone down that particular route if we
look at paragraph S8 as things stand
today please so CD
3.1
mhm page 49 of the
PDF s
y um well actually as I interpret and
apply the policy what balance if any
does it allow me to strike it doesn't
allow any balance at all that was that
was the point I was making it it it
protects um and it protects the
landscape and the intrinsic character
and the beauty of the countryside and be
almost unless you were one of those
criteria it would be impossible to get
past the wording of S8 and and the
inspector concluded
balancing
recognizing well well actually does the
policy apply a test of
recognizing no it doesn't no and your
view please on whether recognizing is
the same has not adversely impacted upon
no it's different it's a different
different test altogether right so in
circumstances where the plan is not
meeting needs your view please on
whether that policy as interpreted and
applied objectively is consistent with
the approach of the
framework no it's inconsistent with with
the the wording of the framework it
doesn't allow any balancing any any um
considerations of what a flap balance
proposal might actually deliver to the
council and so in terms of a a a
proposal for a mix of 50/50 Market
housing assisting in delivering
affordable housing so schemes such as
this which is more restrictive policy S8
or national green belt policy policy
S8 um my learned friend then was taking
you to policy
S1 and the point that he was making is
there is an element of flexibility in
the
plan in two regards I think firstly
there are exceptions in policy
S8 and secondly there is
this I I won't put it as elegantly as as
he did but effectively importing the
Tilted balance into S1 okay
I I want to ask you um in terms of the
flexibility of that tilted balance which
he said would be engaged where there was
not a 5-year Supply or an HDT of 75% do
you recall
yes what flexibility is there in
circumstances where you perhaps have a
5-year Supply and an HDT over
75% but an acute need for affordable
housing what flexibility is there
well there there isn't any as set out in
this one uh an acute need for specialist
accommodation for older people what
flexibility is there again there is
there is not well where there's a
failure against the annualized housing
requirement in the plan what flexibility
is there there there is no you've you've
got to look beyond what the policies are
saying which is why I was coming back to
the officer report to committee who did
exactly that they they they took this as
their starting point and then looked
beyond
what the policy say and and they looked
to see what the development plan was
trying to achieve okay so the point then
is just though about the fiveyear supply
could you just turn to
perhaps um the mppf possibly slightly
tried but mppf paragraph
60 paragraph 6 of the nppf sir
and learning friend was asking questions
about perhaps this is the difference
between us because it depends on
effectively your trigger when you're
meeting the 5year supply in the
HDT um if one looks at paragraph
60 oh apologies 6 we're talking 6 Z
yeah
what has
been what has been and Remains the
government's objective in terms of
housing land Supply to boost the supply
of housing Supply yes right and then if
I look at paragraph 61 what what we have
to recall of course is that the 5year
supply is against a figure which is
lower than the minimum requirement in
the development plan to meet the minimum
economic requirements correct right and
so paragraph 61 is is is talking about a
minimum your view please on whether
meeting the minimum against such a
housing requirement or 75% of the
HDT uh how does that relate to
supporting the government's objective to
significantly boost the supply of
homes yes as we've said in the evidence
it's the the objective
310 as set in the development plan
should be the minimum number
moving forward to deliver the objectives
of the
plan um and then just a a a final point
I think um just about CD
3.3 CD
3.3
um and uh we we see this table table to
it's in the technical note in a slightly
different form in Mr pof's evidence
um table two table two yeah uh and it's
effectively a stock of permissions point
Y just want
to understand this please so just so I'm
clear Mr can we we're we're on the
Strategic housing
land are we on CD 3.3 the AMR the AMR
right yeah the AMR okay and we're at
paragraph So it's table two sir on page
two okay yeah
okay and uh we were looking at this yes
just just a moment ago yeah so what what
we have is we have a a table of planning
permissions
capacity uh then trajectory 2179 and
actual delivery do you see that yes so
so so we have a significant shortfall in
actual delivery to
2023 yeah yes okay now just want to
understand then what is uh going on in
terms of those allocations because if I
look at table three
below I see that S2 c e f and
g i and J are complete
yes H is without planning permission and
we know what CD 5.9 had to say about
that site yes okay so what we're then
left with is
s2a and we we've got
606 and
394 do you see that with uh but the the
it's a reserve matter of of 106 so I've
got a reserve matter of 106 and a detail
of
606 which is 702 yes so um if actual
delivery has been
481 how many homes does that leave me
with which are consent
ented 712 -
481 sorry I'm not I'm not sure that's
quite right I've got so it says detail
permission for are you doing this Mr so
you got
606 yeah got and then you've got a
reserve matter of 106 so that's 712 yeah
and we've had actual delivery of
481 yes
so how many how many are left to be
delivered in terms of
consents I'm happy for you to do the
calcul I'm wondering whether to be
honest this is the best forum for for
this kind of questioning to be honest
because I'm sure you'll appreciate Mr
kuk that you know these are
reexamination points rather than asking
the witness to undertake calculations um
so so I mean it might be better if if
I'm more than happy of course for for
the the figure to be worked out and and
maybe it can be
provided um well I can put it in closing
so it's yeah I I think to be fair to be
fair to Mr Armstrong um he
sorry sorry I thought somebody no um
yeah I I mean I I I I think um he
putting him on the spot to to to do
these calculations I I appreciate the
point you're you're trying to make Mr
can but probably best to um deal with
that maybe in closings um I'm extremely
happy Mr to put the
numbering that it hasn't been said by Mr
Armstrong yeah that was the only thing
that was concerning me somewhat is that
they hadn't actually been in in in the
cross examination so uh you know just
just then this is then the final
question if one looks at
s2b which
is planning permission of 300 120 and
should have delivered by 2022 what we're
told in Table Three is that outline
permission was granted since
2020 and no Reserve matters so what
confidence if any can we have that that
will deliver by
2029 as I say that that site and others
in there are are I don't have an
optimistic view as Mr Coleman does about
those sites delivering
to uh basically complete their their
development by the end of the plan
period yeah and and the planning
permission capacity we're told is
3373 but the 5year supply is 1
1665 so does the local Authority itself
consider those sites are going to be
delivered to 2028 no theyve obviously
got concerns as well yes thank you sir
those are my questions thank you Mr kuk
U much appreciated um well that
concludes the evidence then of of uh Mr
Armstrong and and indeed the appellant
side so um the outstanding matters that
we need
to uh deal with are and I'm not
suggesting we do this now because I
haven't had an opportunity to read the
conditions in details but is
um we need to obviously have a round
table discussion on on conditions and
and on the
obligation
um uh which I think probably would be
best done
tomorrow
[Music]
um did you have any thoughts I
appreciate your your your focus has been
elsewhere yeah but did you have any
thoughts about the need for a solicitor
to yeah I I don't think it will be
necessary um Mr kuk I mean I had a a
brief glance at the obligation o over
lunch and uh I I think given that the
matters are not disputed um I I don't
think it's it's necessary um so I mean
we'll work on the basis that we'll um
we'll open tomorrow at 10:00 to just and
have a round table discussion on on
conditions and and the obligation um I'm
just wondering about closings I mean how
how far are you off in terms of
preparing for closing close tomorrow
morning you could right I I couldn't I
could close tomorrow afternoon yeah that
I think we we've we've made
finish today yeah I mean what I think I
will do is I will have a think uh about
the best approach and um and in terms of
closings um but we'll work on the basis
that we'll we'll do the round taes
tomorrow morning and I'll um in
consultation with you Mr kuk and Mr
Wilcox I'll um we'll we'll decide how
we're going to approach the matter of of
of closings I think we we agree agreed
earlier that um I could undertake um a
site visit unaccompanied so that that
simplifies things in the sense that we
don't need to um have people involved
with that one one point I need to flag
on that sir at the over the lunch break
um two of the members of the public at
the back approach me to extend to you an
offer if you want to to view the site
from within their back Gardens right so
you can see how it appears from uh from
settlements which are current on the
edge so whether or not that is an
exercise that will assist is entirely a
matter for you uh it would however
obviously if you're going to go into
someone's dwelling then it would I think
create the need for particularly if
you're going to go into an obor's
dwelling I think In fairness to the
appellant that would require
accompaniment well I mean the the it
always used to be the case certainly um
the planning inspectorate that we were
always
accompanied in the past but we do now
have these mainly used in terms of
written representation cases where we
have what's called an access required
site visit um which means that in fact
it's just the inspector but the
inspector makes it clear that they you
know they can't discuss any um Pros or
cons of the development so I mean I'm
happy to proceed on that basis if if
you're happy if the appellant's happy
for that um as I say it's it's an
approach that's been adopted now for a
good few years in terms of written
representation cases that we we that in
Times Gone by we we always used to have
the appellant and the
council um available but now planning
inspectorates has worked towards a much
more simplified approach where it's I
think they it's it's it's done all the
time in terms of written representation
cases so I mean obviously I'd need to
let the individuals con concerned when I
was going to turn up I mean I wouldn't
just turn up without let letting them
know but I mean if if if the if Mr kanuk
are you are you happy for me to proceed
on that basis I I I I make it clear to
everyone now that you know I can't have
any discussions about the merits of of
the case uh and I won't be you know
people start telling me how awful it is
or how good it is then I will just say
I'm sorry I can't hear that now so Mr
canuk I don't know if you need to take
instruction on that no I I have done so
there's there's no objection for that I
I would Echo that it does it does
require a degree respectfully of of
self-control um uh uh but also you will
be able to stand on the boundary because
we have given you permission to yeah to
access the site so you you could in any
event stand on the garden boundaries and
it may be that that's an exercise that
you want to do but it's entirely up to
you sir and we don't object to what
you've suggested no I mean I I I I think
it's an accepted practice within the the
planning inspectorate now that that we
can undertake the the such visits
unaccompanied so
um I can proceed on that basis and
advise the people concerned it might be
helpful if the council could provide me
with the details of of who which
properties it is that um that that that
that I'm being asked to view the the
that's yeah I think that would be will
be very helpful um okay okay fine um all
right then well let's um we'll we'll
we'll adjourn for the time being um and
we'll uh resume again tomorrow then at
10:00 if that's okay all right thank you
very much everybody thank you thank you
sir